Il y a trois ans, j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone à propos d'un film que j'avais réalisé auparavant
accompagné d'une offre de suivre la garde nationale du New Hampshire.
Mon idée -- et littéralement, je me suis reveillée au milieu de la nuit,
et nous avons tous eu ces moments.
J'étais enthousiasmée par cet appel téléphonique.
Je venais juste de finir un autre film sur les vétérans de la 2ème guerre mondiale,
et j'ai réalisé que je commençais à connaître leurs histoires,
et j'ai réalisé que ceci était une opportunité unique dans une vie
de raconter au quotidien l'histoire d'un soldat.
Donc cette nuit là je me suis couchée très excitée.
Pas sur de tout les détails, mais excitée.
Ce n'était pas à quatre heure du matin, mais c'était proche de minuit.
Je me suis réveillée d'un coup. Aussi réveillée que possible.
Et j'ai eu cette idée: et si en réalité je pouvais la rejoindre ?
Et créer une relation durable avec les soldats?
Pour raconter l'histoire de l'intérieur, au lieu de l'extérieur ?
Donc j'ai rappelé le Major Heilshorn,
qui est officier aux affaires publiques de la garde nationale de New Hampshire.
Et il me connaissait, donc je lui dis, "Creg?"
Il me répond, "Oui, Deborah?"
Je lui ai raconté mon idée, et vous savez,
c'est un des hommes les plus courageux du monde,
comme le Général Blair, qui au final m'a donné la permission de faire cette expérience.
10 jours après j'étais à Fort Dix.
Et il m'a donné une poignée d'unités.
J'ai choisi une unité -- la compagnie Charlie, troisième de la 172ème,
ils sont de l'infanterie de montagne -- pour deux raisons.
Premièrement, ils sont de l'infanterie.
Deuxièmement, ils allaient être basé à LSA Anaconda,
donc je savais qu'ils auraient accès à internet.
La condition pour mon accès était que je devais convaincre les soldats de se porter volontaire.
Ca ne n'était pas une mince affaire.
Je pense que quand le Major H m'a dit ça,
je ne ne saisissais pas complètement ce que cela impliquait.
Cela voulait dire que, en arrivant à Fort Dix,
je devais aller en face de 180 gars et leur parler de ma vision.
Vous pouvez imaginer l'avalanche de questions que j'ai eue.
La première était,
"Putain qu'est ce que vous savez à propos de la garde nationale?"
J'ai commencé avec les guerres indiennes de la colonie de Bay en 1607 au Massachusetts.
Je leur ai donné une réponse d'environ 9 minutes,
et on a continué comme ça.
Donc j'aimerais montrer un extrait du film.
C'est notre bande-annonce, car évidemment je sais que vous êtes occupés --
beaucoup d'entre vous n'ont peut être pas eu la chance de la voir.
J'aimerais vous montrer la bande-annonce,
et ensuite je vais parler d'une scène en particulier.
Est-ce qu'on peut l'envoyer?
Pink: C'est le Sergent Stephen Pink.
Moriarty: Spécialiste Michael Moriarty.
Bazzi: Est ce que je veux vraiment y aller? Probablement pas.
Soldat: On est pas supposé parler aux médias.
P: Je ne suis pas les médias, merde!
M: Le jour est arrivé. La vie va changer.
Soldat: Le vrai de vrai, gars! T'est prêt?
On y va! Prêt? Irak, nous voilà!
B: Chaque soldat veut éventuellement aller au combat.
C'est un instinct naturel.
P: Si vous laissez la peur vous envahir,
vous ne pourrez pas faire votre boulot.
M: A chaque fois que vous sortez, il y a des attaques.
C'est incroyable.
B: Hey Nestor, ta raie du cul est en plein dans mon visage.
Soldat: IV. Est ce qu'on est sous le feu?
Homme à terre. Homme à terre.
M: Continue, mon frère. Tu veux jouer?
La femme de Moriarty: C'est vraiment dur pour lui de ne pas avoir son père.
M: Ce petit enfant est au milieu d'une zone de guerre.
Petite amie de Pink: Au début, il disait, "Écris moi quelque chose de cochon!"
George W. Bush: La nouvelle démocratie mondiale.
M: Ils sont entrain de me tirer dessus.
P: Vous n'envoyez pas 150,000 troupes là bas
et dites que vous allez créer une démocratie.
Soldat: On a un drive-in au Burger King maintenant.
P: Nous sommes là pour faire de l'argent.
M: Je supporte George Bush. On est pas là pour le pétrole.
Jon Baril: La pire chose dans ma vie.
P: Baril, n'y fait pas attention mec.
Femme de M: Il n'est plus la même personne.
M: Je ne vais pas y retourner.
Kevin Shangraw: Les Irakiens sont ceux que nous sommes là pour aider --
et nous venons d'en tuer un.
Soldat: Le sergent Smith est touché! Le sergent Smith est touché?
Ils sont là! Juste là! Feu à volonté!
Baril: ça sera un meilleur pays dans 20 ans, car nous y étions
j'espère.
Deborah Scranton: Merci.
Une des choses dont j'aimerais parler
c'est d'avoir une conversation sur quelque chose qui est difficile à aborder.
Et j'aimerais raconter l'expérience que j'ai eue ici à TED.
Je ne sais pas combien d'entre vous peuvent l'imaginer,
mais il y a en fait un TEDster qui est récemment retourné d'Iraq.
Paul? Vas-y, lève toi.
C'est Paul Anthony.
Il a servi -- (Applaudissements) -- avec les Marines,
et j'aimerais vous raconter une petite histoire.
Nous étions parmi les chanceux
qui sont rentrés dans la classe avec les caméras Sony et le logiciel Vista.
Vrai? Et nous avons commencé à parler.
Les gens voient mon badge, et ils voient "Les enregistrements de guerre,"
et ensuite nous commençons à parler de guerre.
Nous avons commencé une conversation avec d'autre gens dans la classe,
et ça a continué et continué.
Je veux dire, ont était là pendant une heure, à parler.
Et ça m'a vraiment montré quelque chose que j'aimerais demander
à vous les gars d'y réfléchir et j'espère d'y aider.
Je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous ont très peur de discuter de la guerre,
et de politique.
Et certainement -- car nous allons peut être ne pas être d'accord.
Peut être que ça va vous mettre mal à l'aise.
Comment est ce que nous faisons, pour pouvoir vraiment avoir une conversation?
Et vous savez, Paul était entrain de parler,
et s'est retourné vers Constance est à dit,
"Tu sais, je n'aurais pas cette conversation si elle n'était pas là,
car je sais qu'elle protège mes arrières."
Je vais vous dire, j'était nerveuse.
Car je suis habituée à faire des questions réponses.
ça m'a vraiment touché ce que James à dit hier,
parce que je suis derrière la caméra.
Vous savez, je peux répondre aux questions sur mon film,
mais pour que moi je vienne et que je parle pendant 18 minutes c'est vraiment long.
Donc je voulais dire, "Paul, Je suis contente que tu sois là,
car je sais que tu couvres mes arrières."
Ce film n'était pas à propos de l'internet,
mais il n'aurait pas pu être fait sans lui.
Les enregistrements des gars prenaient environ deux semaines pour arriver d'Irak.
Pendant ce temps, avec les soldats -- on s'envoyait des emails et des chats.
Je n'ai pas tout sauvegardé,
car je n'ai pas réalisé au début
que c'est quelque chose dont j'aimerais garder une trace.
Mais il y a eu 3,211 emails et chats ainsi que des sms
que j'ai réussi à sauver.
La raison pour laquelle je quantifie c'est que nous nous sommes embarqués dans cette aventure ensemble
pour pouvoir vraiment aller au plus profond.
Donc je voulais vous montrer un extrait,
et ensuite je vais vous expliquer comment est ce qu'il a été fait.
Si nous pouvions envoyez l'extrait.
Pink: Aujourd'hui c'est sport.
On aime donner à ces insurgés une chance égale.
Donc qu'est ce qu'on fait, on roule avec les fenêtres baissées.
Car vous savez, nous avons clairement l'avantage. Je plaisante.
On ne roule surtout pas avec les putain de fenêtres baissées.
Ce n'est pas vrai. Très risqué.
Whoa.
Soldat: Juste là.
P: Très bien, on va aller vers ce site.
Soyez avertis, on quite Taji maintenant.
On pense que l'explosion a eu lieu juste en dehors des portes de Taji,
nous nous dirigeons vers cet endroit maintenant.
Soldat: C'est une putain de voiture piégée!
Soldat: Enfants de putain!
Soldat: Prenez vos gilets!
Hey, allez vers le putain -- ouais, ouais.
Quiconque, quatre éléments allez vers la porte!
P: Sheriff un six, ou quiconque des quatre éléments,
nous avons besoin de vous à la porte de Taji tout de suite, fin.
Homme: Je vais vous y conduire.
(Voix)
P: Restez accroupis. Allez vers la droite.
Prend ta trousse, prend ta trousse de secours!
(Cris)
P: Il y a eu beaucoup de victimes.
Probablement 20 morts, ou au moins 20 ou 30 Irakiens blessés.
P: ça ressemblait juste à -- vous savez,
quelqu'un qui, qui avait jeté une pièce de monnaie à travers un gars,
et c'était juste comme -- si il n'y avait pas de sang provenant des blessures.
Tout était cautérisé,
et c'était comme si il y avait un vide qui -- qui traversait son corps.
Voici la scène au nord.
Ils viennent juste de retirer un corps brulé, ou un demi corps d'ici.
Je ne pense pas qu'il restait quelque chose en dessous de son abdomen.
ça c'est du sang.
Et vous savez, vous marchez,
et vous entendez les morceaux de peau et --
c'est tout ce qui reste
Je me souviens d'avoir fait trois intraveineuses, et des bandages à plusieurs blessés.
Des soldats assis dans un coin du mur en sac de sable, tremblant et criant.
Des médecins qui étaient terrifiés et ne pouvaient pas exercer.
J'ai entendu plus tard que les blessés Irakiens n'allaient pas être soignés à Taji.
Ils peuvent travailler à leurs porte pour des piécettes, mais ne peuvent pas mourir là bas.
Ils doivent mourir dehors.
Si un de ces médecins incompétents me demandait d'arrêter le traitement,
Je lui couperais la gorge sur le moment.
21:00, et c'est juste notre équipe
qui repasse les événements d'aujourd'hui dans nos têtes,
que nous le voulions ou non.
Anchor: De nouvelles violences en Irak.
Deux attentats à la voiture piégée ont tué huit Irakiens et blessé des douzaines
près d'une base de la coalition au nord de Bagdad ...
P: On est aux nouvelles.
Je me sens exploité et fier en même temps.
J'ai perdu toute foi dans les média --
une plaisanterie de mauvais goût dont je préfère en rire que d'en prendre parti.
Je devrais vraiment remercier Dieu d'avoir sauvé mes fesses.
Je vais faire ça, et ensuite je vais me masturber.
Car ces pages sentent comme Lindz,
et il n'y aura pas de temps pour se masturber demain.
Une autre mission à 06:00.
Deborah Scranton: Maintenant -- (Applaudissements). Merci.
Quand je parlais plus tôt, d'essayer de raconter une histoire de l'intérieur, au lieu du contraire ---
une partie de ce que Chris a dit si éloquemment dans son introduction c'est la fusion.
C'est une nouvelle façon de faire un documentaire.
Quand j'ai rencontré les gars, et que 10 d'entre eux ont accepté de prendre des caméras.
Au total, 21 ont fini par filmer.
cinq soldats ont filmé la totalité du temps.
Il y en a trois montré dans le film.
J'ai appris à propos de Taji parce que Steve Pink m'a envoyé un email,
et une photo attaché de ce corps brulé près de cette voiture.
Et le ton du mail était,
vous savez, ça avait été une très mauvaise journée, assurément.
Et j'ai vu dans ma fenêtre de chat que Mike Moriarty était à la base.
Donc je l'ai interpellé et je lui ai dit,
"Mike, est ce ce que tu peux s'il te plaît aller faire cette interview avec Pink?"
Car la chose qui manque le plus souvent c'est,
dans l'armée c'est ce qu'ils appèlent une "douche à chaud".
C'est cette interview immédiate après que quelque chose se soit passé, vous savez.
Et si vous laissez passer le temps,
ça arrondi les angles.
Et pour moi, je voulais vraiment ça.
Donc, pour pouvoir avoir cette intimité,
pour partager l'expérience avec vous, les gars --
il y avait deux points de montage populaires --
il y avait une camera sur la tourelle -- la tourelle mitrailleuse,
et sur le tableau de bord du Humvee.
Dans la plupart des Humvees, on a fini par monter deux caméras dessus.
Donc vous avez l'expérience en temps réel, ok?
L'interview que vous voyez est une que Mike a été faire
24h après ce qui s'est passé.
Steve Pink lisant son journal
est arrivé cinq mois après qu'il soit rentré à la maison.
Je savais à propos de ce journal, mais il était très, très privé.
Et vous savez, vous gagnez la confiance,
spécialement en faisant des documentaires, à travers vos relations.
Donc ce n'est que cinq mois après son retour à la maison
qu'il a voulu lire ce journal.
Les images des infos que j'ai mises là dedans pour essayer de montrer --
vous savez, je pense que les médias traditionnels essaient de faire du mieux qu'ils peuvent
avec le format qu'ils ont.
Mais la chose que je sais que vous tous avez entendu plein de fois,
des soldats américains disant,
"Pourquoi est ce qu'ils ne parlent pas des bonnes choses que nous faisons?"
OK, ceci est un exemple parfait.
L'équipe de Pink et une autre équipe ont passé la journée entière en dehors du camp.
Ils n'étaient pas obligés aller en dehors du camp.
Il n'y avait pas d'américain blessé là dehors.
Ils ont passé la journée entière en dehors du camp à essayer de sauver des Irakiens --
les Irakiens qui travaillent au poste.
Donc quand vous entendez des soldats se plaindre,
voilà de quoi ils parlent.
Et je trouve que c'est un cadeau tellement merveilleux qu'ils partagent ça,
c'est une façon de se rapprocher.
Et quand je parle de cette polarité que j'ai à tellement de Q & Rs,
et les personnes ont vraiment des opinions préconçues.
Mais on dirait que les gens ne veulent pas en entendre trop.
Ou écouter. Ou essayer d'avoir un échange.
Et je suis enthousiaste comme personne, mais je pense vraiment --
vous savez, différent orateurs ont parlé de leur inquiétude pour le monde,
et mon inquiétude c'est que nous devons avoir ces conversations.
Et nous devons aller dans des terrains dangereux où on pourrait, vous savez,
nous pensons que nous savons.
Mais nous devons laissez cette petite partie d'ouverture d'esprit, vous savez.
Il y a un tel fossé.
Et pour moi, c'est d'essayer de combler ce fossé.
Je vais vous raconter une histoire.
J'ai -- On me demande souvent, vous savez, pour moi
quel sont les meilleurs moments d'avoir travaillé sur ce film.
et aux projections, inévitablement -
vous savez, je suis sûre que chacun de vous parle à des conférences --
normalement vous avez des gens qui restent et veulent vous poser plus de questions.
Et normalement les premières questions sont,
"Oh, quel genre de cameras avez vous utilisé?"
Ou vous savez, ce genre de choses.
Mais il y a toujours quelques gars, presque toujours, qui sont les derniers.
Et j'ai appris au fil du temps que ceux là sont toujours des soldats.
Ils attendent jusqu'à ce que presque tout le monde soit parti.
Et pour moi, une des histoire les plus profondes qu'une personne m'ait confiée,
qui ensuite est devenue mon histoire, était --
pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont pas vu le film, et ce n'est pas un révélation --
c'est très fréquent, il y a beaucoup d'accidents de civils
où les gens sont en face du Humvee et ils se font tuer.
Dans ce film, il y a une scène où une femme irakienne est tuée.
Un soldat est venu me voir, et vous savez, vraiment proche --
à 30 cm de moi.
C'est un gars costaud.
Et il m'a regardé, il a sourit,
et ensuite j'ai vu des larmes dans ses yeux.
Et il n'allait pas cligner.
Et il a dit, "Mon artilleur était entrain de jeter des bonbons."
Et je savais ce qu'il allait dire.
L'artilleur était entrain de jeter des bonbons.
Ils avaient l'habitude de jeter des bonbons aux enfants.
Les enfants viennent trop près, très souvent.
Et il a dit, "J'ai tué un enfant.
Je suis un père. J'ai des enfants.
Je n'ai pas eu le courage de le dire à ma femme.
J'ai peur qu'elle pense que je suis un monstre."
Je l'ai pris dans mes bras, bien entendu,
et j'ai dit, "ça va aller."
Et il a dit, "Je vais l'amener voir votre film.
Et ensuite je vais lui dire."
Donc quand je parle du fossé,
ce n'est pas seulement pour ces personnes qui ne connaissent pas de soldats.
Qui évidemment existent -- vous savez, ces jours.
Ce n'est pas comme la 2ème guerre mondiale, où il y avait un front de guerre, et un front local,
et tout le monde paraissait impliqué.
Vous pouvez passez des jours ici et ne pas sentir qu'il y a une guerre.
Et souvent j'entends les gens dire,
qui peut être savent que j'ai fait ce film,
et ils disent, "Oh, vous savez, je suis contre la guerre mais je supporte les soldats."
Et j'ai commencé à leurs demander,
"Bon, c'est bien -- qu'est ce que vous faîtes?
Est ce que vous êtes bénévole à une association de vétérans?
Vous allez voir des gens?
Est ce que -- si vous découvrez que votre voisin y a été est ce que vous allez le voir?
Pas nécessairement poser des questions, mais voir si ils veulent discuter?
Est ce que vous donnez de l'argent à des associations caritatives?"
Vous savez, evidemment, comme Dean Kamen qui a travaillé sur cette chose merveilleuse --
mais il y a d'autres œuvres caritatives où vous pouvez sponsoriser des ordinateurs pour des soldats blessés.
Je pense je défie chacun de dire --
qu'on opérationnalise ces termes quand on dit qu'on support quelqu'un, vous savez?
Êtes vous amis avec eux?
Est-ce que vous vous en soucier vraiment?
Et je voudrais simplement dire que c'est mon vœu, et j'aimerais vous demandez à vous,
s'il vous plaît, tendez votre main.
Et vraiment prenez les dans vos bras.
Merci.